[موسيقى]
العملاق لامبي وناكولا لوم
شكران أو أوباما ألدن هنا - لا يوجد شريف يعيد
تحديد ما إذا كان لدي
باسيلا إجرامية - فكرت هنا حتى أقصد
ملء عيون القطة، إنها رسالة حب إلى
أطبائنا، رسالة حب إلى  ممرضاتنا
وغيرهم من المتخصصين في الرعاية الصحية الذين
يخاطرون بحياتهم من أجل حياتنا،
نحن نحتفل بشجاعتك وبطولتك
allomere shuriken Ashura مدتها
دقيقتان أنثوية تعوي الشب Phil
Heflin musafir بعد أن قامت إيفيتا أنيما
بتصوير الرجل حتى إيلينا داماتو
شيري كوتو  المواطن العالمي USA Today
Booker Bell هو مادة مخلوقة جديدة
تطلب من الطمعين في أوقات فراغنا
تقليدًا أكثر للبالغين، انظر مرحبًا Lee
Herman LAM، علامة البيانات ثم Stevie
Wonder الذي كان على بعد دقيقة واحدة من Rolling Stones
كان Elton John Paul McCartney مختبئًا في
Faton  نخبة الأوبرا العيلامية الأوغندية أليسيا
هنا أندريا بوتشيلي أينما انتهى
[موسيقى]